our president president Trump he comes
up a lot on the shows and I have to ask
you
he's had he has had a difficult yes well
not a difficult first year was a
difficult following Obama cos Obama no
drama Obama Obama was just cool malas
this is somebody was very calm yeah
didn't make a lot of fuss and Obama
could sing now that was too cool for
school when he was amazing if he would
be up there no we're gonna do it nice
and then you go
[Music]
[Applause]
supposed to follow that what's he gonna
sing the cookie no no hi 19 much yeah
[Laughter]
you have any any hope meeting with Kim
jong-un if this really happens is going
to go well you have any hope at all I'm
just saying to everybody maybe
something's going on maybe whatever you
think of Trump maybe we need a ten-year
old mindset to go over there and just
look at and go it's all about China okay
it's totally about China yeah I think
that is there a method to his madness
that's my question or is he just a loose
cannon because he always just crazy [ __ ]
then he goes drives it back right right
like you know they did they understand
was too nice you know far as the nuclear
peninsula we're gonna work together and
some people in the area we're gonna do
things people do when they do this long
and they're like what yeah
then Trump comes out fire and fury okay
fury and fire I'm just doing kind of a
William Shatner now tiny fire erupted
Trump was never I mean Obama is never
gonna say the little rocket man no
little rocket man little little rocket
man
no we call it little rocket man cuz you
short of stature and you fire
projectiles into the air Trump really
should sing no one knows what it's like
to be the bad man to be the sad man
behind unstow mother my point is this
your party's why I point is this as far
as Trump's concerned look if he solves
the you know the thing in North Korea
doop de nuke de nuke denote right if he
got we gonna give him the Nobel Peace
Prize oh that's a showstopper
Hollywood California yeah
I mean we have to write you up there I
love I love the Nobel you know belly and
tremendous people many people are saying
I love prizes I love Cracker Jacks
magnifying glass a whistle ring we'll
see yeah you'll see do you think he's
now some people may trying to make the
case that he's not fit to be President
what's your take on that I'm just
waiting I've noticed a pattern M he
comes out he says crazy and then he
backs up second he goes uh it's obsolete
NATO's obsolete next day I love NATO
that tremendous people I mean he's doing
it over and over a fire and fury and I
know we'd love to make peace if you D
knew I just think that when he meets kim
jeong-hoon in the room I will pay I
would pay pay-per-view wouldn't you
wouldn't you love to see I wouldn't you
love to see those two in a room together
and see what really happens once the
door I know I just have a feeling that
Trump will sort of dislocate his jaw
just a delicious
he's wait you think he's gonna eat Kim
I'm not saying but we live in a weird
world much more with Dana Carvey just a
second cigarette
you